Transcriptor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Silvina Katz
Hace 5 años, por esta época
más o menos, en Navidad,
estaba en San Antonio, Texas
pasando con mi familia
y creo que cometí uno
de los peores errores de mi vida,
o en ese momento lo creí:
le regalé a mi mamá
un iPhone de Navidad.
Cuando uno le regala
a las mamás tecnología,
con el regalo tiene que venir
la enseñanza de cómo se usa
el aparato que uno le regaló.
Y en el caso de mi mamá y el iPhone,
vino bajar Facebook y WhatsApp,
que son las dos aplicaciones
que mi mamá más usa.
Mi mamá, una persona que yo pensaba
que no era muy buena con la tecnología,
empezó a ser la persona que me escribía
más mensajes por WhatsApp al día:
me saludaba a las 7:30 de la mañana
y si yo no le respondía al segundo,
me preguntaba por qué no le respondía.
(Risas)
Y si yo no le respondía
a ese mensaje al segundo,
por qué yo no le respondía el mensaje,
(Risas)
ella me decía que
si yo estaba brava con ella.
(Risas)
Y yo: "No, mamá,
yo no estoy brava contigo,
lo que pasa es que no estoy
todo el día pegada al celular,
esperando a que me mandes un mensaje
y que yo te tenga que
responder inmediatamente".
Pero no sólo eso,
mi mamá se convirtió en la persona
que más cadenas de
WhatsApp me mandaba.
(Risas)
Sí, me imagino y sus tías y los abuelos,
pero mi mamá, les prometo que era
la que más cadenas de WhatsApp mandaba.
Y la mayoría de las cadenas de WhatsApp
que mi mamá me mandaba.
eran noticias falsas.
Y yo soy periodista.
Trabajo en dar información.
En dar información veraz
para que la gente esté informada.
Entonces le preguntaba a mi mamá,
"Mamá ¿de dónde sacaste esa información?
¿Por qué crees que esa noticia es real?"
Y ella me decía, "Porque me la mandó
mi amiga Patricia por WhatsApp".
(Risas)
O me decía, "Vi esta noticia en Facebook"
o "Encontré esta noticia en Internet".
Encontrar la información para mi mamá
en WhatsApp, en Facebook o en Internet
era suficiente para ella decir
que esa información era real
y que era una noticia verdadera.
En América Latina, en promedio,
los ciudadanos nos estamos pasando
en Internet 37 horas a la semana,
eso en promedio son 5 horas al día
conectados a Internet a través
de un celular o a través de un computador.
Sin embargo, las horas
aumentan para los millenials;
este es el número de horas que yo
paso en mi celular al día en promedio:
5 horas 22 minutos.
Los millenials en promedio
se están pasando en frente
de un celular o un computador
40 horas a la semana.
Hoy, más que nunca,
estamos conectados a Internet
y tenemos acceso a mucha información,
a noticias del mundo entero,
y es maravilloso.
Pero también estamos conectados
a la mayor cantidad de desinformación
que hemos encontrado nunca.
Internet es una plataforma maravillosa
pero ayuda a manipular a la gente.
Y ayuda a manipular a la gente
porque nos estamos desinformando
a través de Internet.
Y no se trata del nivel
educativo de las personas.
Si Ud. es más educado
no significa que va a compartir
menos noticias falsas.
Si Ud. es menos educado
no significa que va a compartir
más noticias falsas.
Acuérdense Uds. que el presidente
Uribe compartió una noticia falsa
o ha compartido muchas.
Hubo una en particular
cuando se firmó el Proceso de Paz,
en donde compartió
una portada falsa del Daily News
que decía que el Estado colombiano
le había regalado el país a las FARC.
Obviamente esa era
una noticia evidentemente falsa.
Pero no solo el ex presidente Uribe,
también el ex alcalde
de Bogotá, Gustavo Petro,
que también ha compartido
noticias falsas a través de Internet.
O por ejemplo,
cuando compartió un video,
en ese momento del candidato
Iván Duque que estaba editado.
O cuando compartió una foto
del presidente Iván Duque,
que era evidentemente un montaje
leyendo un libro al revés.
Entonces si nuestros líderes políticos,
si los líderes de opinión
están compartiendo información falsa,
¿qué diremos nosotros?
¿Por qué no vamos a compartir
información falsa?
¿Por qué mi mamá no va a enviarme
una cadena de Whatsapp que no es verdad?
¿Pero por qué nosotros hacemos eso?
¿Por qué compartirmos
información que no es real?
Porque las personas
que crean las noticias falsas,
apelan a una herramienta muy poderosa,
que son nuestros sentimientos.
Y una vez que se apela a los sentimientos,
se pierde completamente la razón.
Y la gente que escribe
y crea esa desinformación,
apela a dos sentimientos muy importantes,
que son el miedo y la rabia.
Apenas Ud. siente miedo
y rabia, cuando lee algo,
inmediatamente quiere compartirlo;
porque ya la razón se fue.
Porque Ud. inmediatamente quiere
mostrarle a sus amigos, a su familia
lo que le produjo rabia
y lo que le produjo miedo.
El estudio más importante que se ha hecho
de desinformación en EE. UU.,
lo hizo la universidad de MIT,
y descubrió que una noticia falsa,
tiene un 70 % más
de probabilidad de ser compartida
que una noticia que es real.
70 %
Y, ¿por qué?
Porque la verdad es aburrida,
las noticias falsas tienen
unos titulares rimbombantes
que dan ganas de compartir.
Por eso cuando Ud. vea un titular
que le parece demasiado estrambótico,
sospeche, porque puede
ser una noticia falsa.
Ese mismo estudio de la univerdad de MIT,
se dio cuenta que
desde el 2006 hasta el 2016,
los bots, que son estos mecanismos
que se utilizan en Internet
para volver viral la información,
compartieron la misma cantidad
de noticias falsas que verdaderas.
Entonces no eran los bots
ni los mecanismos digitales
los que estaban viralizando
la información falsa.
No era culpa de elllos.
Entonces, ¿de quién es la culpa?
¿Quién viralizando
información que no es real?
Nosotros, los seres humanos.
Somos nosotros
los que estamos desinformando,
somos los que estamos compartiendo
información que no es real.
Y eso, ¿por qué hace daño?
¿Por qué deberíamos preocuparnos?
Porque los seres humanos
tomamos decisiones
basados en los hechos
y en la información que recolectamos.
Y si recolectamos información falsa,
información que no es real,
pues terminamos tomando malas decisiones.
Pero además, podemos terminar dañando,
a través de una cadena
de Whatsapp que es falsa,
a una persona que podría ser Ud.,
podría ser su mamá, podría ser su hermana.
Podemos terminar dañando una marca,
que se demoró años en construirse.
Podemos terminar dañando una institución,
o incluso, terminar dañado un país.
Porque las noticias falsas
que más se viralizan,
a pesar de que todas se viralizan,
las que más se viralizan
son las noticias políticas.
Y si Ud. comparte
noticias políticas falsas,
está haciendo que las personas tomen
decisiones equivocadas en un futuro.
Pero quizá lo más peligroso
de compartir noticias que no sean ciertas,
es que están matando gente.
En agosto de este año en México,
dos personas fueron quemadas vivas,
por una cadena de Whatsapp que era falsa.
La gente en México los mató,
eran un tío y un sobrino,
los quemaron vivos porque pensaron
que eran los responsables
de haber robado y extirpado
los órganos de unos niños.
y era una cadena de Whatsapp
que era mentira.
Pero eso no solo pasa en México.
En Colombia, en octubre, en Bogotá,
en la localidad de Ciudad Bolívar,
a un hombre que trabajaba en construcción,
que tenía 23 años,
con dos hijos, lo mataron.
Y lo mató, los golpes de 150 personas
que pensaron y creyeron
por una cadena de Whatsapp,
que ese señor era
el violador de unos niños;
cadena de Whatsapp
que era falsa, también.
Lo confirmo la polícía.
Pero la policía también confirmó,
que había descubierto
seis cadenas de Whatsapp similares
que también eran falsas.
Y en la India, en julio de este año,
según los medios de comunicación,
doce personas fueron asesinadas
por cuentas de cadenas
de Whatsapp que eran falsas.
Así que la invitación
que les quiero hacer hoy aquí,
es a que piensen que Uds.
son productores de información.
Que así como consumimos información,
también producimos información.
Somos lo que se denomina, 'producers'.
Y ser productor de información,
trae una gran responsabilidad.
¿Por qué?
Porque somos muy poderosos.
Acuérdense lo que decía Spiderman,
"Con un gran poder viene
una gran responsabilidad".
Por eso hoy, los quiero invitar
a que la próxima vez
que reciban una cadena de Whatsapp,
que vean una noticia en Facebook,
o que lean una noticia en Internet,
cumplan tres pasos básicos,
que pueden parecer obvios.
Pero a pesar de lo obvio,
no los estamos haciendo regularmente.
Primero: No comparta algo inmediatamente.
Apenas le llegue la información,
no lo comparta.
Segundo: Investigue
la fuente de información.
Haga su tarea, mire
quién le manda la noticia,
cuál es el medio de
comunicación que lo publica,
¿aparece en más de
un medio de comunicación?
¿Quién es el autor?
Y tercero: Mire la fecha.
Fíjese en la fecha de la publicación.
Porque una noticia puede
haber sido real hace 5 años,
pero si Ud. la lee hoy,
está completamente descontextualizada
y termina siendo falsa.
Todos Uds. tienen
un poder enorme en sus bolsillos
y en este momento en sus manos.
Levanten los celulares, los que
tienen un celular inteligente acá.
Todos, porque veo a todos
tomando fotos y chateando.
Esa herramienta es muy poderosa,
Uds. tienen un poder enorme en sus manos
y por eso lo les quiero dejar yo hoy aquí
es que cuando reciban información,
respiren, piensen, y ahí sí compartan.
Pero recuerden también,
que se vale no compartir
y guardar su celular en el bolsillo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)